[Music]
so
i was born in eastern province eastern
part of zambia
in 1966 i was a driver
as well as a carpenter
[Music]
i love the most especially moving up and
down because i knew
so many places as you drive i really
enjoyed the job
when i was 34 years my life changed
forever
that day i saw a blister developed on
the
left leg after some hours it was another
blister
on the other leg and then my legs turned
black
i went to hospital they discovered that
a gas can clean
that's a disease i was affected with
then
the doctors just decided for this man to
survive
you just have to amputate both legs
it pained me i nearly committed suicide
i thought that my life has ended i'll
never drive again
i'll never do my carpentry job
but through god's mess and then the
support of
some religious people i came back to my
senses i just had to accept to say
let it be the way it's supposed to be
[Music]
after being amputated i can no longer
drive but i used my carpentry
skill to do the carpentry job
[Music]
one day my friend asked me to do this
carpentry job at
his workshop zambian association for
children with disabilities
this association deals with mobility aid
for children with disabilities
i was really touched one time when i
went around the
children's world to see young
children face some difficulties how to
move
i was so touched so that i know i've got
that
skill to make them good in crutches to
help them
to move early
i can do it despite the way i am i can
still help them
so that they don't feel depressed but
they don't feel bad the way
they are
from 8 to 16 30 making some
crutches some braces special chairs and
any standing frames
deficiencies for children's disabilities
when i see a child using the crushes i
make
i feel very good and
when i see a child putting on some
praises
i really praise god because he's the one
who gave me
strength to make those things i know
that
in future those advisors i make they can
make them
walk and they can make them to be
perfect persons
i always make some differences for
children with disabilities
but i feel and i believe one day
someone is going to do wonders for me
again
like making some artificial limbs for me
for me to stand and
run and do whatever a normal person can
do
and now that dream has come true i'm
very excited about it
there's an organization called 500 miles
which have supported me to buy me some
artificial limbs i know that one day
i'll drive again
[Music]
[Music]
life can change anytime and we have to
accept it
the way it comes to you
i age people who can be found in the
situation i am
to have that heart of accepting
whatever can happen to them
have that heart of prayer every time
because things can change anytime
you want to take some steps
ups and downs in life so you just have
to accept
the way things come to you
[Music]
you